hallo mein name ist so kann endlich will
kommen heute zu einem neuen video rage
und ich sitze hier wieder auf meinem
bett dettmar bett aber hier und immer
wenn ich hier sitze mache ich ja quasi
mein gott ich bin total schief in der
kämmerei ein stativ ist kaputt und ich
habe kein geld deswegen habe ich einfach
ein handtuch als stativ halterung
genommen ich zeige euch mal kurz wie es
aussieht
ich sitze hier weil ich euch etwas sagen
muss und das habt ihr nämlich auch schon
im titel gelesen und zwar keine gaming
videos mehr ist nicht so schlimm wie es
sich jetzt aufwärts moment anhört denn
ihr das video gerade an dem tag sehen
oder video raus kommt also am 31.10
siebten also an dem sonntag dann erkläre
ich mal ganz kurz die allgemeine
situation gerade ihr wisst ja dass ich
studiere und ich schreibe eine klausur
jetzt morgen am montag bzw sprecher der
klausur weil es in mündlicher englisch
klausur ist und einmal nach uni ist es
nicht so dass ich irgendwie vier monate
frei habe und das ist dann der komplette
juni juli august september sondern ich
habe nur der september frei das fakt hut
ab das sage ich dir noch oft die denken
sich aber damit musst du jetzt leben
ich würde sagen dass ich dafür im
gegenzug alt ultra fiel auch lerne was
halt auch die sache dass ich vergess
halt nur auch sehr viel ist ein anderes
thema meine uni sagt auf jeden fall ja
du hast nur den september frei das juckt
aber sehr viele leute nicht weil wir bei
uns keine anwesenheitspflicht an das
heißt ich habe das ganz offen ich gehe
oft einfach nicht hin weil ich habe
youtube termine habe und
andere business kam sachen und arbeit
unseres und der september der monat den
ich frei habe da ist nirgendwo mehr was
los also ich war übel soft bedeutenden
urlaub die halt einfach so juli und
august frei
keiner hat september frei außer ich und
das ist blöd deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht ich fahre vom zweiten achten
also von jetzt im dienstag bis zum 15
oder 16 8 in den dollar auf das heißt
weniger videos wochen ich bin nicht so
oft getragene freunde spaß bei der ta
was da draußen einige leute geben sollte
die sagen augen ich hätte gern doch
videos von luca keine sorge ich fahre
mit irgendwie 30-40 freundin in den
urlaub also die sind alle schon dort ich
muss nur noch quasi jetzt morgen am
montag die klausur schreiben
beziehungsweise sprechen dies ist von 14
bis 14 uhr 30 in der uni und dann fand
einen tag später also am dienstag
morgens früh los an die nordsee und
fahre dort dann in den urlaub und werde
das eher engine und werde dort quasi vom
zweiten achten bis zu 15 16 achten also
zwei wochen bleiben da ich aber ein
youtuber bin der wöchentlich fünf sechs
videos hochlädt kann ich natürlich nicht
einfach so in urlaub fahren ohne woher
videos zu machen die dann quasi einfach
so hochgeladen werden wenn ich im urlaub
bin also das kann man ja bei youtube
machen dass es so geplant hochgeladen
wird dann hab ich damit kein stellen
es ist heiß es scheint keine sonne ist
und 30 grad aber kommen wir jetzt
endlich auf dem titel dieses videos jahr
höher und zwar habe ich bzw bin gerade
dabei das weiß jeder dass videos seht
habe ich wahrscheinlich schon videos
produziert allerdings nicht für jeden
tag also wie vorhin schon tausend mal
gesagt ich fahre 14 tage weg das heißt
eigentlich wenn alles gut laufen sollte
sollten das so 14 videos sein da ich
allerdings werten nicht täglich
hochladen kann und möchte weil ich nicht
so ich weiß nicht also ich finds in
letzter zeit die coolere nicht so 45
videos die woche bringen bei denen ich
mich so ein bisschen mehr dahinter setzt
und so ein bisschen mehr was mache als
irgendwie dass ich sieben videos woche
bringen die dann aber nur dreieinhalb
minuten gehen wenn ihr versteht was ich
meine ich wollte einfach nur sagen dass
ich halt so ein ablaufplan auf meinem
handy habe den könnte ich mal ganz kurz
zeigen so sieht so ein ablaufplan aus
meine damen und herren also das ist doch
google tabelle ich habe das
wahrscheinlich gerade verpixelt damit
ihr keine titel sieht und was ich
irgendwie hochladen aber so sieht das
ganze quasi aus das sind die ganzen
sachen drin die ich hoch werde für jeden
tag möchte ich so ein bisschen zu
erklären ich habe er farben hinter
gemacht also alles was grün markierte
ist vom regen ok habe ich schon
aufgenommen bearbeitet und hochgeladen
alles was ihm viel geld besser als ja
muss ich auf jeden fall noch vorm urlaub
macht man alles was blau ist heißt das
den videos die ich im urlaub machen
werde am liebsten will ich euch das
gerade wirklich anhand des kalenders ihr
direkt so step by step erklären wann
welches video kommt allerdings ist das
ja eine überraschung sein und
andererseits irgendwie möchte ich auch
nicht alles preis die massen
zweiwochenhoch lade ich will nicht dass
mir dann gesagt wird von wegen hier in
einem ablaufplan hast doch gesagt diesen
tag kommen lassen das video dann klappte
nicht und dann sind leute traurig und so
wisst ihr was ich meine
ein optisches wir machen weiter ich
würde der oder herbert zwölf minuten das
video sollte vielleicht drei minuten
gehen ja nicht aber schon wieder
rom rom natürlich um jetzt mal zu einem
schlusspunkt zu kommen ich bin 14 tage
im urlaub von den 14 tagen kommen an
zwei tagen keine videos an sechs tagen
komfort produzierte videos und an sechs
tagen kommen videos im urlaub und alle
videos die ich im urlaub auf nehme diese
nicht an den letzten sechs tagen
beispielsweise sondern das ist alles
durcheinander gewürfelt damit ihr damals
ein bisschen abwechslung drin hat die
sechs videos nicht im urlaub aufnehme
sind beispielsweise in welche challenges
am strand oder irgendwie so real life
sache das ist auf jeden fall alles real
life und da ist kein gaming mit dabei
das heißt schon mal sechs videos von den
zwölf videos die in den 14 tagen kommen
sind keine gaming videos und außerdem
die sechs sich vor produziere davon sind
zwei videos nur gaming videos die beiden
gaming videos sind die nächsten dienstag
und danach den dienstag nämlich dass
minecraft beta let's play was sicher
ungeschnitten hochladen
aber sonst kann ich nicht wirklich sagen
es im nächsten zwei zweieinhalb wochen
kein gaming kommen wird also ich werde
jetzt nicht sagen okay spielt cod und
hat das hoch oder ich viel akinator oder
so das einzige was als sein könnte ist
dass ich soll das machen wie dieses
higher love game aber das ist für mich
kein gaming das ist mittlerweile
unterhaltung oder so und jetzt mal alle
infos videos in einem satz
zusammenzufassen ich fahre ab dienstag
14 tage in den urlaub in der zeit werden
zwölf videos kommen einerseits videos
die ich im urlaub mit freundin aufnehme
und andererseits auf videos die ich hier
zu hause vor produziert habe wie
beispielsweise real live videos oder
irgendwelche witzigen websites oder
sowas
ein jet set also das ist quasi alles was
wir heute sagen wollte wenn es euch
gefällt wie ich das ganze strukturieren
will also wenn es euch gefällt das meer
real life kommt belastet auf jeden fall
leichter vielleicht treffe ich jemanden
von euch im urlaub und ich bin dann weg
videos kommen vielleicht doch nicht so
viele aber ich brauche eine pause aber
abonniert doch vielleicht trotzdem einen
kanal danke